hello reject nation it's Greg Alda here
and I'm John we just found out the
Sicario to Soldado trailer dropped boy
howdy
so I was like of course we got check
this [ __ ] out right now before I do that
just wanted to give a quick thank you to
the folks over at Stardust where we're
trying to get to 2,300 followers right
now it's an awesome app that allows you
to do reviews for 30 seconds for any
film TV show or trailer so would love it
if you guys could download the app and
follow us first because we want to get
to twenty three hundred we're loving it
over there posting plenty GJ wow this
has gotten bigger
how would you define terrorism uses
violence to achieve political goal
administration believes the drug cartels
[Music]
[Music]
you want to see this thing through I'm
gonna have to get dirty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone
[Music]
cool cool
I really like the way that was that was
done I knew Emily Blunt wouldn't be
returning for this and it makes sense
cuz her story really does wrap up it
would make more sense of rep Anissa del
Toro and Josh Brolin and keep the story
going as opposed to Emily Blunt started
with Emily Blunt star in the first one
she was being brought on this mission
and as the mission kept going deeper and
deeper she kept discovering just how
ruthless and dirty and violent no rules
bar kind of deal she was in but that
kept getting unveiled more and more as
the movie kept going as opposed to here
starting off with benissa Latour and
Josh Brolin you could just hop into this
is their world you know this is you
don't have to do any of that build-up to
the nasty dirtiness it's like no it's
gonna start off do we know how josh
brolin a Benicio del Toro operated from
the first one and it's just gonna be
this chaotic mess which I'm looking
forward to a hell of a lot and I
wouldn't be fooled by the trailers if
you really pay close attention and look
like we were looking at maybe three or
four action sequences that they were
cutting back and forth to because the
first one doesn't have a lot of action
sequences it's really a lot of character
tension suspense build-up yeah I was
taking a bit was like this looks like a
no I wouldn't be fooled by it because I
can't pay attention to the imagery and
it looked like they were cutting back
and forth between three to four action
sequences that will probably play out
and then I feel like the moment that
probably sold it was when Minnesota tour
was like do an arcade game on is gone
yeah remember when I played point blank
Oregon's Macomb on a hot streak lately
this is first sequel I believe he's
writing at least it's a completely
different directors it looks like they
probably have the same cinematographer
on board no maybe it's shot visually the
same there's a tone that seems similar
even though it's just my theory there's
three or four action sequences that
they're cutting around you could be
right it could go down exploitation vibe
and just go no holds bar but feel like
I'm I like that to make it bring a lot
more height at least knowing who's
involved in all that I feel like this
could definitely toe that line the
violence still looks gritty and harsh
like the first movies is you know and it
would be appropriate I think for a
sequel like they're calling this
Sicario saga and usually when this
happens I feel like the scope inevitably
changes of course this is the first
movie I didn't even think that that was
a movie that had a sequel in its
atmosphere anywhere and now there is one
so I can see it being you know like
maybe a faster paced movie maybe a bit
more of a action-packed movie in some
regard but I can also see how it could
just as easily dive into the lifestyle
and and you know there's plenty for
cartel vines bad people to cover I just
feel like they're leading with action
here so now like it the first Acharya
movie did that to the first card I'm
moving me to look like there was a bunch
of action with the Rosen I feel like
with denis villeneuve movies in general
they do that and movie but but yeah it's
like the guys sell it yeah they're gonna
give me the cool like assault rifle but
he said let's horror doing point blank
it looks good and I feel like Benicio
del Toro and Josh Brolin were there more
interesting even though I felt Emily
Blunt really held that movie and carried
that film Josh :
and Denis of those who are were the more
interesting characters and the question
is though they work strongly as
supporting characters now that though
the two main leads will it still carry
on a strong it's been aged of the Toro
and Josh Brolin so I imagine they will
he's a collector and I think overall it
is very fascinating to see that they're
taking the corrupt characters which made
them so intriguing in the first
installment and now making them the
leads because they're kind of viewed as
potential bad guys in a way in the first
one yeah and this one they're making
them the lead main characters you know
interesting to see this with a far less
sympathetic anchor anyway guys what do
you think of Sicario to solo the so this
is alive oh so Soldado you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell you can follow John
and I on the Stardust app download the
app and follow us first please make sure
to go check out our patreon become a
patron jack today it's like a second
youtube channel people would love to
have you